quand ils sont venus m'arrêter ils m'ont
tout enlever d'agresser sa soeur et mon
primé maison hugo tout prix mais mon
prix de l'argent d'avant aussi donc j'ai
vraiment perdu beaucoup moi ça veut dire
qu'en réalité et sincèrement je vous le
dis j'ai rien gagné vous avez perdu
combien mais limitant votre vie en
millions d'euros à peu près beaucoup tu
veux que je te dise il te le dis à toi
tu auras malade est un conseil [ __ ]
non non mais il a envie d'avoir mal à
atteindre
avec belgique ont été gagnés mon père
m'a pas dans sa robe à peu prêt à y
aller moi et moi je vais des
entrepreneurs et vous n'êtes pas
capables d'en ménager non mais c'est pas
ça c'est d'aller gagner combien 200
millions d'euros de quoi
être 23 millions moi je dois moi non
pour moi que pour lui et moi j'en crois
moi je dois 283 millions d'euros il ya
une chose que je vais te dire on se
revoit dans le sérieux en un je me donne
trois ans pour les rembourser je le dis
devant les juges quoi qu'il arrive je
rembourserai ma dette et je serai quitte
voilà c'est de l'honneur que je me mets
mais ils m'ont mis quand même huit ans
de prison
c'est normal et c'est justifié mais à
l'argent vous avez des pensées aussi il
ya ce que vous avez dépensé ça vous en
avez profité que tu nettoyer les
oreilles
bien j'ai dit tu as we re met d'accord
mais vous pouvez pas vous place un vrai
cours viennent parce qu'on a vu on a vu
toute l'épopée las vegas des trucs de
fou c'est quoi tout le plus fou que
s'est effectué
à lorsque rien alors bien qu'il ya un
truc que j'ai fait c'est qu'est-ce qui
l'a raconté le procureur est-ce que je
vais parler d'une légende aussi je
voudrais raconter téléspectateurs une
histoire qu'on m'a raconté sur toi est
ce que c'est une légende ou pas une
histoire de pato merguez
dans un restaurant qui ne faisaient pas
et tu leur dis je veux des partenariats
ce que
c'est vrai chez ducasse c'est ça ouais
alors racontez nous l'histoire c'est
quoi eh ben je suis arrivé j'avais tu
sais quand tu vas en boîte a envie de
sortir tu envie d'aller manger et puis
j'avais envie de manger des pâtes aux
merguez way et le problème c'est qu'ils
avaient pas de merguez cacher ouais je
mange casher enfants halal casher c'est
pareil c'est important que des ouais
bien sûr que c'est important que je dis
pas ce que je veux pas remettre de la
saucisse est ce que tu veux
et je leur ai demandé et je leur ai dit
tu étais chez ducasse et il veut pas
dire le nom sacré dû faire de la pub
c'est un très grand restaurant étoilé
et j'aurais demandé d paterberg et ils
m'ont dit il y en a pas ici des pato
bergen on comprend pas c'est quoi les
pâtes aux merguez judy et diminue tu
fais des pâtes aux merguez timide wrong
way il m'a dit combien geof
sinon